so i've got another prime number
generating formula for you uh so this
one is
more modern it's it was 1947 a
mathematician called mills and he found
this formula he said there exist numbers
which we're going to call theta the
greek letter theta where you raise it to
the power 3 to the power n
and
you actually then have to round it down
that gives you
that gives you fractions so you actually
round it down to the nearest whole
number
which you write like this
that's the symbol for rounding it down
it says there's a there exists a number
like this that will always give you
primes for every value
of n
so you might have n equals one n equals
two n equals three and every value is a
prime
the smallest
value for theta
where this will work it's called mill's
constant i'll write it out for you
so it's called theta a mills constant is
1.3063783863080
something something something something
so it's uh
you can see it's not a whole number so
the value you get when you raise it is
going to be
it's not going to be a whole number and
you have to round it down let me just
try the first few to show you what i
mean
let's do n equals 1. let's use my
constant you put it in so then it's 3
to the power 1 so it's just cubed so
what i'm going to do is for each time
i'm going to take this constant and then
raise it to the power
3 to the power n and i'll do that for n
equals 1 n equals 2 and so on
so n equals 1
3 to the power n is just 3 so that's
going to be theta cubed that's the first
prime and what is the answer what is
theta cubed
theta cubed is
2.229 something something something
you round it down
so the prime is 2.
hey we've got that is prime and we and
in fact every number should be prime
let's try the next one
let's do n equals 2
so this is going to be 3 squared it's
theta to the power 9.
so take the constant to the power 9. and
that is going to be
11.082 something something
round it down you get 11.
so you get gaps it's not consecutive
primes but every one is a prime you get
11. that's the next one let's do n
equals 3. so i now need theta 3 to the
power 3 27
theta to the power 27
is 1 361.000
something something something
1361 is a prime as well
let's do n equals four
theta to the power 81
yeah 252 million one hundred thousand
eight hundred and eighty seven
oh yeah that's clearly a problem which
is clearly in five regions of prime
point something something something but
you round it down but you're actually
guaranteed to get a prime every time do
you know what my conclusion is
that number's awesome i know i i
completely agree that number is
completely awesome so the the rock stars
of maths are pi
and and e and these uh golden ratios and
things like that it's not nearly as
famous it's a constant that gives you
primes
brilliant i love it is it proven that i
mean there's a lot of ends you could put
into that equation is this a proven
thing yeah this is proven this this this
is proven
so you might think then well what so
what's the big deal we've we we've got a
formula to find guaranteed
primes how amazing is that and the
problem is did you notice how big the
powers were getting
the powers very quickly become so huge
that even computers can't deal with the
problem
so the next one
uh n equals five
is theta to the power
and this is about
1.602
times
10 to the 28. once you start getting
bigger than that it's
it you can't do it the computers can't
cope with that
the other problem is
you need to know this constant to a
great accuracy
because what i've written out for you
let's say if i terminated it there
isn't accurate enough
to tell me what the next prime is the
next prime actually is something huge
we'll put that on the screen i think
instead of writing it out
but
this
was not accurate enough
to work it out
that's a bit of a problem you need to
know theta very very accurately is theta
rational does theta have enough we don't
know
we don't know how amazing is that we
don't know if theta is irrational or not
that's that's a cool question as well we
don't know
there is one of the other problems with
theta
is at the moment
we don't know
any way to really work it out
apart from taking one of the mill primes
you take one of the male primes
cube root it
and theta is approximately that so i'm
afraid there's no there's a it's a bit
of a circular argument
we haven't got a good way of working out
theta
you have to know the primes in the first
place to work out theta oh well i'm not
so impressed by anything i know so you
can see why it's not so practical
one of the things that we might be able
to do is
if riemann's hypothesis is true
riemann's hypothesis is a very important
hypothesis in mathematics that hasn't
been proven yet it that isn't a
millennium prize and it's about it's
related to primes and how they're
distributed
if that is true it probably is true
if it's true then we have another way to
find male primes
using that method
we can now calculate what theta is
probably going to be
it's been calculated up to
about 7 000 digits but it is relying on
if the riemann hypothesis is true which
hasn't been proven it's probably true
we have worked out
larger male primes
and we have worked out theta to
a large number of places
our thanks to audible.com for supporting
this video
they have a huge range of audiobooks you
can listen to great for putting on your
handheld device or listening to in the
car and you can download a free book at
audible.com numberphile this is the part
where we get to recommend a book which i
always enjoy and today i'd like to
recommend foundation by isaac asimov the
first in a brilliant series of books
probably my favorite series of books
ever so go to audible.com numberphile
get a free book and why not check out
anything by isaac asimov but especially
foundation or any of its sequels and
prequels